تونس امام تحدي سياسيا جديد يدعى الناخبون
تونسيون يوم السبت الانتخابي برلمان جديد
برلمان بدون صلاحيه فعليه في انتخابات
تشريعيه تقطعها غالبيه الاحزاب السياسيه
المعارضه انتخابات ترجى لاول مره على
الافراد وليس القوائم الحزبيه وفق دستور
الجديد اقراه رئيس تونسي قيس سعيد بعد
استفتاء لم يحظى بمشاركه واسعه في الخامس
وبسبب تعليق الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد
العمل بالدستور السابق وتغيير النظام
السياسي من برلماني الى رئاسي يرى هذا
الخبير السياسيين البرلمان الجديد المتكون
من 161 نائبا لن يحظى بصلاحيات حكم واسعه
هذا البرلمان
بالسلطه لانه لم يكن قادرا على مسائله
الحكومه او توجيه اليومي اليها وهذه
الانتخابات التقطعها غالبيه الاحزاب
السياسيه
الانتخابات التشريعيه حزب النهضه التي كان
اكبر الاحزاب المهيمن على البرلمان طوال
10 سنوات اذا انه يعتبر ما يقوم به الرئيس
انقلاب على الدستور وعلى الثوره اما
الاتحاد العامه التونسي للشغل النقابه
العمليه الرئيسيه في البلاد فترى ان لا
طعم ولا لون للانتخابات القادمه شعور
يتقاسمه العديد من التونسيين بسبب النظام
الاقتراع الفردي فان غالبيه المرشحين
البالغ عددهم
1580 شخصا غير معروفين لدى الراي العام
التونسي
في الدوله التونسيه بالعكس
في الانتخابات
كبيره وقدر الخبراء ان تكون ضعيفه